[music playing]
>> Let's face it none of us
really think about our leftovers
beyond their function as a
convenient alternative
when we're
feeling lazy.
But did you know there's a lot
more to last night's meal
than meets the eye.
[music playing]
>> During World War I
it was considered patriotic
to consume every
last scrap of food.
And during the Great Depression
re-purposing your meal
avoided the
sin of waste.
[music playing]
>> Grocery prices fell in the
1960s and throwing food away
was considered
a sign of affluence.
Inexpensive fast food and
frozen meals also proved
more convenient
than cooking at home.
[music playing]
>> As women
entered the workforce,
they were less willing
and had less time
to get creative
in the kitchen.
[music playing]
>> According to
a recent study
by the nonprofit
organization ReFED
Americans toss out 27
million tons of food each year.
Why?
Because they forget
about their leftovers,
grow bored of them
or simply dislike them.
[music playing]
>> Access to nutritious meals
is a real concern in America
and advocates believe
that leftovers
can play an important role
in cutting back waste.
One solution is to make eating
your leftovers a priority again
through public
service campaigns
like the ones during
World War I.
So, eating leftovers
doesn't mean you're lazy.
It might just
make you a Patriot.
>> March On.
Celebrating Women
Who Changed the World.